this week illinois congressman adam
kinzinger announced he will not be
running for re-election next year
i cannot focus on both a re-election to
congress and
a broader fight nationwide i want to
make it clear this isn't the end of my
political future but the beginning
oh he wants to focus on a broader
national fight much more important than
continuing to slum it in a mere
congressional district but wait is that
the real reason or could it have
something to do with the fact that his
announcement came just hours after a new
congressional map would have forced
kinzinger to fight a competitive primary
for a new seat let's ask one of the
people who would have been fighting him
for that seat gop congressional
candidate catalina lauf catalina what do
you think um you're sad you won't be uh
facing off against kenzinger
you know what this guy embodied
everything that was wrong with our
elected officials he was a career
politician that spent you know his last
term in congress uh sitting there
bashing his own party instead of
fighting against the radical progressive
agenda so of course while we were ready
to take him on and had a lot of support
not only here in illinois but also
nationally i think america is happy to
see uh somebody like him gone for good
and and it's time that we have real
servant leaders back in congress that
actually want to fight and do good work
for the people and provide a voice
for americans look we're coming up on
really bad issues here there are real
kitchen table issues uh the economy
hyperinflation the border crisis where
was adam on these issues he was nowhere
to be found he was on msnbc cnn boosting
his own profile talking poorly about his
own party we've had enough of that we've
had enough of these career politicians
and we need real servant leadership now
yes
well that's right that's his that's his
new district the media but um quickly
catalina you're you're still fighting
right are we going to see you in
congress
you absolutely will uh we are fighting
head to catalina for congress.com
we have we've earned over a million
dollars here in support against adam
but given what's going on now we are
still in the fight and we're going to
still bring back positive changes here
for illinois we are not going anywhere
well fantastic you are always welcome
here great to see you tonight we really
appreciate it thank you for having me
all right we'll be right back
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else